[Música]
comenzamos nuestra sección dedicada a la
información de salud con nuestra
periodista especializada en el tema más
rumberos a la mar bienvenida y me
encanta ese azul celeste de hoy muchas
gracias maría clara qué piropo bueno y
comenzamos en argentina con las últimas
informaciones que se conocen sobre el
brote el brote de legionelosis sí pues
lamentablemente tenemos que empezar hoy
la crónica reportando un nuevo fallecido
que se dio a conocer ayer por este brote
ya son seis en total los que se han
registrado en argentina 13 personas
están afectadas además 9 de ellas desde
casa pero 4 están ingresadas dos de
ellas además graves recordemos que todos
estos casos están relacionados con el
mismo centro de salud en el san miguel
del tucumán en el norte del país y desde
mediados de agosto se empezaron a
reportar estos casos no casos de
neumonía de los cuales además se
desconocía el origen por suerte
recientemente hace poco los últimos días
las autoridades de argentinas ya dijeron
que habían encontrado el culpable de
este brote escuchémoslo
el agente etiológico causante de brotes
se llama legionela es una bacteria que
se está simplificando el
apellido es posible que sea una legión
de la que llaman pila no hay ningún
virus de conocido buen hogar pero para
quienes no sabemos qué es la legionela
explíquenos qué es y cómo es la
enfermedad que provoca pues se trata de
una bacteria de la legionela es una
bacteria empecemos por ahí además hay
más de 50 tipos de esta bacteria no
todos enferman a los humanos
aproximadamente la mitad tienen la
capacidad de enfermar a las personas
además no todas causan neumonía como ha
sido en este caso en argentina también
pueden causar una fiebre que se llama
fiebre de pontiac parecido a una gripe
muchas personas ni siquiera saben que la
pasan cuando la pasan por lo parecido a
los síntomas de un resfriado común la
bacteria más común es stalin o los is
pneumophila que como su nombre indica
genera neumonía es la que se cree que
está provocando este brote en argentina
aunque todavía estamos a la espera de
que se confirme con totalidad desde la
infección hasta hasta los primeros
síntomas pasan unos 2 a 10 días es decir
el periodo de incubación de 2 a 10 días
aunque se han registrado casos un
poquito más largos empieza con todos
fiebre dolores de cabeza pero puede
también terminar provocando como hemos
visto casos de neumonía en los dos
pulmones y en los peores casos llegar a
la muerte especialmente peligroso para
personas inmunocomprometidas o que
tengan algún tipo de enfermedad previa
en el pulmón que sean personas fumadoras
o exfumadores en este caso la tasa de
mortalidad está entre el 40 y el 80 por
ciento en el cambio en las personas con
buen estado de salud o sin ningún tipo
de condición previa está alrededor del 5
10% muy importante recordar que no se
transmite de persona a persona de hecho
esta bacteria crece en aguas maltratadas
que normalmente estén en una temperatura
media o alta por ejemplo estamos
hablando de refrigeración es industrial
es de humidificadores en estos casos
donde las aguas están estancadas ahí es
donde pueden crecer y mediante pequeñas
gotas de esta agua al vapor no lo que
conocemos como aerosoles contagia a las
personas pero no pasa de una persona
infectada a otra algo que ayuda mucho
por ejemplo pues al control de estos
brotes no es un virus nuevo se descubrió
en 1976 precisamente por un brote
región americana y de ahí también viene
su nombre en general los brotes pues no
es que sean comunes pero hemos visto a
lo largo de los últimos 20 años como
esta enfermedad ha ido creciendo y se
han registrado en distintos puntos del
mundo algunos pequeños brotes de la
enfermedad a tener cuidado entonces con
las aguas estancadas marc y ahora quiero
preguntarle algo el kobe 19 porque hay
una novedad y son las vacunas inhaladas
cómo es esto pues es una de las grandes
noticias que estábamos esperando que se
hicieran realidad y aunque no va a ser
todavía ni gran escala en el nivel
global en china ya en realidad una de
estas primeras vacunas inhaladas contra
el commit 19 la vacuna desarrollada por
cansino se ha aprobado como método de
dosis de refuerzo no es la misma vacuna
que habían aprobado en forma de
inyección en este caso pues se convierte
en nebulizar se convierte en una especie
de spray y se aspira por la boca también
hoy hemos recibe la noticia de que en
india se ha probado también el uso de
emergencia de una vacuna que se inhala
en este caso por la nariz de la
farmacéutica barata bayo tecno entonces
bueno son buenas noticias vamos a ver
cómo se van desarrollando bueno y cómo
funcionan
lo básico digamos es que es lo mismo que
el cuerpo entra en contacto con algo que
le haga desarrollar una respuesta inmune
puede ser el aire de mensajero como
hemos visto con el kobe 19 la proteína
de espiga del coronavirus en otros casos
por ejemplo en una vacuna que ya existe
contra la gripe se trata de un virus
inactivado entonces el principio básico
es exactamente el mismo pero tienen
diferencias en el tipo de respuesta
inmune que provocan en el caso por
ejemplo de las vacunas que se inyectan
intramuscular como las que hemos vivido
hasta ahora contra el commit 19 son muy
buenas en provocar una respuesta inmune
sistémica es decir que los anticuerpos
circulen por todo el cuerpo en despertar
la memoria de las células t que son las
que luego también ayudan a combatir el
virus una vez esté ya ha infectado a la
persona en cambio las vacunas nasales
generan una respuesta inmune local en
este caso en las mucosas de la nariz o
de la garganta que son la primera
barrera ante la infección de kobe 19 y
por eso podría ayudar a prevenir hasta
el contagio no sólo a combatir la
enfermedad sino prevenir el contagio de
kobe 19 algo que podría revolucionar
pues el manejo de la pandemia hasta
ahora no hay estas dos opciones
aprobadas localmente veremos qué tanto
se extiende
pero además también es especialmente
importante pues en los niños o en las
personas que sean aprensivas a las
agujas eso le iba a decir que ojalá se
extienda pronto para quienes le tienen
temor a las agujas mar gracias por estar
con nosotros muchas gracias a ti y
nosotros seguimos con nuestros